Here are three psychological triggers
that will persuade people to buy more of
your stuff. Number one is scarcity.
People have to understand that what you
are selling is not for everyone. Whether
it's spots in a cohort or number of
physical products that you could sell,
scarcity increases the demand for it.
Number two is urgency. People have to
have a reason to buy today. Whether you
are putting a deadline on extra bonuses
that they get or the price is going up
or a discount is expiring, you have to
give people a reason and a time that if
they don't buy by X date, then they will
lose the opportunity to gain the
benefits of your offer. Number three is
proof. If you have testimonials,
screenshots of results, and anything
else that can prove that your product is
worth buying, and not just you telling
them, but you showing them through other
people's stories, results, and words,
you will increase buyership tfold. To
recap is scarcity, urgency, and proof.